welcome to this video playing super
cheese from Australia yep hahaha let's
do the tango yeah quite often igloo
transposed to one of my if one of my
normal openings like this the tango yeah
it's not particularly great but also not
particularly bad as one of those
openings that is a bit underestimated I
believe okay let's go a5 and c6 okay he
allows me to play a 4 then I'm happy to
get this in
getting see 50 interesting it's a very
sharp move
huh okay um wonder Knight g4 is this may
be a move from 93 and taking just taking
may be interesting a4 seemed a bit early
but not not surely but 93 it is pretty
problematic I don't really see what he's
doing now
don't see a good move here
no no 93 is a problem Brooke f3 looks
wrong well I can take a for ya this is
an interesting try of course 93 will win
the exchange but I'm not sure about the
strategic consequences but this is this
interesting I just take it keep this
option in the position and well he has
really weakened all of his dark squares
and still I don't really see a great
move I'm him maybe it was better to take
the material but not totally sure so
what is he doing there he wants to go to
deform hmm interesting to deform
hmm ok ok let's just play play a normal
move there covering c5 a bit and go from
there hmm how do I continue from here ok
at least thats that's easy just go back
I've 95 here or no I don't have it ok
because of my unprotected rook there
it's a bit awkward 96 lat g6 what is
wrong with 96 96 Bishop f6 Queenie three
wins the Queen he has to go to g5 larity
can go to g5 but it's not bad at all
Queen g5 I can play 97 getting a queen
tradin difficult for him to not treat
Queens
Queen g 597 yeah that's not bad if i get
queens traded those weaknesses III the e
palm leaf I've will be a vector not sure
what he's doing there what is the point
of thinking I can go to d4 I'm sorry
about that sorry yeah you can go to
default that's not out of the picture at
all I was thinking Queen g5 is zone you
move anyway but that's not true Queen
d4s quite quite reasonable yeah it is
quite reasonable okay 94 in fact might
be might be on the agenda here
94 yeah okay it's funny way to repeat
move Queen age 4 is a repetition I don't
want the draw but I currently I don't
really see how to play if I go would be
eight maybe he has 94 the queen is
unprotected so let's go back and I don't
want the draw I just want to reassess
the situation here Queen deform can I go
and now I have this move interesting
didn't expect him to avoid the draw I
think white should be content with the
draw
okay i can check him but it's not doing
much okay just put this here for Bishop
g7 I have to get my hooks connected
finally yeah that we spent a huge time
in both both of us all 94 that looks
like a problem protects g5 at x f2 at
xe3 it's really quite quite a good quite
a good then okay okay i can t g3
actually why is the Queen going
white resign yeah that was it was quite
okay I think I mean I didn't want to
draw there but I repeat it anyway a
little bit what's unsure how to do this
I like my position there because of the
structural soundness but it's not not
that clear I think I have to do this the
90 form is quite uncomfortable here
originally I was thinking I just I just
played Bishop d7 or something but he has
this night before move and this is quite
awkward I have 98 maybe I mean okay
that's not a great move but it's not
like losing the components of this by
the way that's also very nice that's a
very nice move that that just rinse
forward ok so we going back as good and
now he continued with this oh oh oh I
missed something here age 3 is very aged
6 is very strong Bishop takes Queen e2
wow wow that's great his queen is
trapped yeah I'm covering that it's it's
it's a very cute cute line Queenie 2mb
I'm just winning after that computer
sees that merely of course I didn't see
it at all funny funny what's possible
sometimes ok this makes screen g5 real
mistake I didn't see that at all I just
saw that this is ok getting me a good
regrouping guarantee i think i'm
comfortable the structure is good and i
don't really have to worry about too
much yeah this is blonde during the game
but ok that that's that that this
happens sometime ok interesting a funny
Queen trap there with age 6 I didn't
consider that at all ok well thanks for
watching